nouvelle vidéo de gaming entre mecs
entre couilles 100% testostérone
ouais
[Musique]
on est avec marion qui est vraiment une
gameuse hardcore on peut le dire tu fais
partie latine millénium qui la plus
grosse ligne 3 de france on n'influence
d'anjou adoum avait joué au premier opus
précédents trésor -tim dépenses en
france ok d'accord je rigole j'attends
de voir que tu vises vraiment entre les
deux yeux jamais appel d'une précision
total ils étaient plus pc opus console
classé bat ça doit vraiment à l'aise et
sûrs de manette
donc on a avec 6 i mua ça fait ça tombe
l'az est ce qu'on peut appeler à part
ton prénom nom d'accord ça met tout de
suite l'ambiance on peut commencer le
gaming mais parce que je sais pas
comment je vais passer la manette
elle est comme ça le mec qui tiennent
mal comme ça tu sais d'avancé que ça a
fait un gros gamer sur un certain on ice
and stop mais on peux t'appeler jardin
peuvent plus jeunes pour les intimes ou
lire un bon il faut rappeler que
thénioux buzz gaming n'étudie pas de
gamme yêrêfê ce qu'ils aillent voir
absolument pas que je suis tu parce
qu'ils nous parce que bien que mal lutté
dans la première pièce depuis un quart
d'heure oui maintenant et faire du
naming
vous n'avez pas cette suite faisait du
gaming est jamais trop envie d'en faire
au début j'avais peur tu sais pas ce que
ça fait un peu de jouer un joueur d'or
j'ai commencé à jouer à ce petit jeu on
me disait que toutes les boues thermales
là alors on est dans une session gaming
avec correa bonjour rien sa guise et
koala l'origine aux canons algérien
bacalao pays merde en même temps aucune
part et que tu me racontes tes origines
chanteur me faire dézinguer en fait donc
comme on est dans un gué nuit avec le
monde plus de fans que tout seul c'est
que tu vas jouer à ma place et ouais six
énormes un coup encore on m'attaque non
non non ah ouais d'accord donc vraiment
un beau palais quand on fais pas ça
qu'on dit camping on est avec morgane
skate paradise
voici ce à luton chaîne arrête de
cuisine c'est ça de cooking oui c'est
quoi le le plat que tu ne sais pas faire
je suis pas trop ça et je fais que du
sucre mais je mange que du salé mais je
ferai comme super skis et lâche en
pratique c'est avec ça donne à ce salut
salut
donc tu es youtube de beauté est ce que
tu pourrais me donner des petits
conseils de beauté par les cheveux crois
tu vois mais tes cheveux c'est voulu
comme ça qui nous claque ça
malheureusement pas voulu gêner comme ça
mais non la vente avait les cheveux plus
courts j'ai étudié menu petits conseils
de beauté serait qu'avant ça dépend si
tu te mets qu'ils n'ont pas à ce que tu
as des mecs qui met deux lentilles ferme
à ce que toi c'est pareil on est avec
lucie décosse comme son accoutrement le
laisse à penser championne de tennis
quoi ouais bien le gaming trop s'appelle
bourse est un jeu qui sort 193 et
plusieurs opus et à ses tout derniers
auxquels on joue en exclu ou peut-être
tu es contre la violence carrément rr
martiaux c'est pas du tout violent
donc tu as été championne de france de
judo championne de france championne
d'europe championne du monde s'est
énervé d'accord ok le calme ag total je
vais partout on reparlerait s'arrête en
judo je connais que david douillet
flamand la méga base z90 attention quoi
ça c'est intéressant très très bien
certains hommes c'est un homme décédé et
mourut alors ah ouais ok y'a pas de
respect pour lui pis tacler on a eu un
peu de mal et je vais au niveau du torse
comme normal tu fais du gaming but
commun de temps depuis décembre d'accord
c'est super frais s'est fait après
bouton niveau attendre au niveau 10
voilà c'est ça et sur la chaîne view
qu'est-ce qu'on peut retrouver comme
type de vidéos et de la beauté la bonne
conseil conseil quoi pas j'essaie de
comprendre une criante en s'intéressant
à ce que je conseille aux garçons pour
séduire des filles est naturelle ouais
comme ça allait bien j'étais betty
versement à liszt suis sûr et certain
tout sauf le maquillage les normes
éthiques ainsi thomas je me marierai
jamais c'est sûr même été pire quand
paul savage qui passe le poisson je t il
non justement de se faire le poisson que
c'est vraiment le truc dans le métro
faire ça si je les complète de démission
complète de fou non mais sérieux c'est
pas mon vrai nom c'est une grosse grosse
compétition les garçons jouent entre
garçons et nous l'étions la compétition
a mis aussi
donc on a beaucoup moins que les garçons
dès qu'on fait en france ou en europe et
je fais deuxième troisième
lorsque l' extrême aux couleurs des
quand tu gagnes c'est quoi tu gagnes un
prix du galon
il ya de l'argent à gagner les journées
des équipes de filles entre lesquels tu
veux plus longtemps et en défense et
donc la compétition cet été est en train
de casser le cliché nul qui dit que les
accusés mais qui jouent aux jeux vidéo
est aussi plein de mecs qui jouent aux
jeux vidéo voir tu connais un peu ce
jour trois essais c'est le quatrième est
inconnu d'historique de la licence c'est
mon copain qui connaît le jour à 5 m eur
oui en tout cas t'as pas appris à jouer
ça c'est sûr au de suite quand je t'ai
fait une petite surprise
je terminais un gâteau non en plus à ton
effigie sérieux ouais tu vas omagad trou
style et sa voix va compter un gâteau
avec mon style
donc ça que je tiens à préciser que
c'est le chat de monsieur chaque été ce
de ce chat derrière moi cergy
mais c'est moi south park et baby
siffler ça joue beaucoup
on vous reconnaît qu on va faire un
gâteau tu vas sur ma chaîne talent tuto
pour le reproduire
moi je suis là pour eux complètement
juste juge et a aucun problème je me
moque de toi mais pas trop quand même
parce que je vois que tu as des biceps
attend après voilà je suis un peu vexé
en fait ma virilité est en train de
partir
au revoir la virilité regarder un petit
vélo de fitness tu déconnes patois c'est
vraiment ça va dans l'exercice course
qu'il faut donc c'est vraiment pour les
gens qui sont passionnés sport ban c
pourra les personnes qui veulent se
maintenir pendant pas besoin de moi pour
regarder des vidéos vraiment quand
vraiment facile mais de ça rien bah oui
est ce que tu peux après un exercice de
fitness que je peux faire mais en jouant
aux jeux vidéo faite fin des squats je
peux ce côté je peux soit en même temps
[Musique]
on va faire tout cas c'est un moyen doit
faire option difficulté ultraviolence
hockey dont on est en mode ultra
violence
le décor étant de fait de gaming
montante 80
là tu dis que de ça ou tu peux pas dire
si je peux et gagner ma vie avec ça je
vais faire attention parti pour c'est un
rouleau veulent c'est cool qu'il n'y a
pas assez d'argent parce qu'ils trouvent
que tu nous prouvent clairement
conteneurs aujourd'hui c'est la façon
dont joue un mode pour les mecs qui ont
torché le jeudi fois et ça ça prend un
peuple du joug pensons que pas te faire
chier un arrêt de plissés pourquoi tu
puisses comme ça projet que ce tome et
l'a étonné mais qui se ferme et est
donné les effets un médecin ouais merci
pour cette leçon de makers sa part of me
démaquiller je veux dire que je
recommencerai plus jamais maquillant
madame pipi c'est que ton parfum c'est
pareil d'une maîtrise en maternelle un
petit dépôt de bus de la grand mère et
fait du jeu depuis que des gagnants
ouais j'ai tendance à 6 ans donc
vraiment hâte a baigné dedans plutôt
petit quoi au départ on va dire que
c'était vraiment un sport à loisir et tu
retires à mesure avec la compétition
j'avais envie d'être championne pas j'ai
persisté jusqu'à être chanté dans la qui
souhaite un vrai besoin de chez toi 10
rebonds le suis la personne la meilleure
au monde dans cette discipline c'est pas
mal via une prise de corps à corps que
je montre mon goût très simple
violence dit la veuve qui partent un
kimono s'amuser à pétain il ya un max de
monde je tâche pas mourir ainsi tu meurs
je te tue en techniques de judo
d'accord je peux mourir sacré que la
mort
[Musique]